[Musique]
c'est dans un hôtel de l'ouest que se
sont rendus 21 nouveaux diplômés du
certificat de sauveteur secouriste du
travail des personnes ordinaires qui
méritent un traitement extraordinaire
car ce sont des aidants familiaux
leur quotidien est totalement dédiée à
un proche handicapées ou malades mais de
façon non professionnelle à ce que moi
je ne travaille pas je suis dans des
mamans je ne suis pas déclaré je n'ai
pas de fiche de paye je n'ai pas de
statut et là on un diplôme de secourisme
qui est génial parce que ça nous permet
déjà de
[Musique]
d'accéder aux premiers soins avec notre
aider voilà souvent les déchus ou quoi
que ce soit bon on n'a pas les premiers
gestes souvent on s'affole comme ça mais
suivie d'une formation avec
des formateurs spécialisés bien sûr sous
la direction du gip sap
ça nous a beaucoup aidé à connaître les
premiers gestes à intervenir même
passion notre et des métaux courants de
la vie de chat la route à l'est avec
n'importe qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce premier diplôme égal depuis monde
entier qu en même temps je suis très
fier de vous diplôme
[Musique]
vous avez dit elle ça va être
certaines réponses existent et des
dispositifs améliore les conditions de
vie ainsi en 2010 7,6 en aidant était
formée à l'initiative du jb laisse
happer avec un financement du
département
mais la problématique est complexe car
leur quotidien et complexes aide les
malades ce soit par an maman papa savent
ce que c'est que la laine la difficulté
mais ceux qui sont en bonne santé et non
personnes dévalent à cesena sarkozy que
de s'occuper d'un malade d'être à 100
il mérite d'être valorisé aujourd'hui
par exemple cette remise de diplômes
c'est gratifiant pro c'est la première
fois qu'ils sont mises à l'honneur
seule une politique ambitieuse et
volontariste permettra de changer les
choses car même si la solidarité
familiale existe bien les 48 milles et
dans d'aujourd'hui doivent être
accompagnés pour que demain le modèle
réunionnais perdure que nous avons
envoyé un courrier à la conférence des
financeurs pour lui demander que cette
année et y ait des appels à projets
concernant les aidants parce que les
aidants ont eux aussi droit à avoir le
maximum d'attention
premièrement et aussi à avoir un répit
convenable et un repos convenable parce
que cela pourrait nous arriver à tous
cet enjeu de société pose la question de
quel modèle nous voulons pour notre
avenir
mettre nos proches en établissement ou
les garder dans la famille certains ont
déjà choisi c'est eux qui ouvrent le
chemin
[Musique]